YouTube in the past has consistently
argued that their algorithms policies
they're often geographically dependent
that's something that we were told it's
something that many of you have been
told if that's the case I would implore
YouTube could you please explain to me
your shareholders and in all likelihood
a congressional hearing why you believe
it most appropriate in serving your
audience to block the content of the
United States presidential candidate
exclusively in the country in which she
is running on Friday Hillary Clinton
Rodham case you thinking of someone else
Hillary Rodham Clinton claimed that
tulsi gabbard well she claimed that
there were people who were Russian
assets and then it was confirmed that it
was Tulsi Gabbard right confirmed that
she was talking about Tulsi Gabbard
accusing her being a Russian asset and
Tulsa's response had her trending number
one on Twitter I think it was was this
on Friday it was last Friday that's when
we were looking into this case oh she
was a number one trend actually I think
like number one through four because one
might have been Tulsi another might have
been rushed an asset another might have
been Gabbard the point is she was the
belle of the ball with many verified
check marks by the way and pundits
running with the story fighting over
whether she was a Russian plant so
during this time we decided to again
well Tulsi Gabbard was in the spotlight
run some comparative searches on YouTube
when we set our VPN so I want to be
clear this is the crescendo share it
pirate this in case it gets removed when
we set our VPN to a non United States
country and we search for Tulsi Gabbard
her channel and the videos from her
channel all showed up first yet again
when we switched our searches to the
United States however nothing
exclusively in the United States the
country in which she is currently
running for president you would receive
no results from Tulsi gabbard's channel
or her videos until scrolling past the
first page here's a video screen
recording in just in case people try to
say that we've doctored it by the way
these video screen recordings will be
available as clips on YouTube should you
want to use them
for articles so that Friday you search
she's trending one on Twitter all of a
sudden boom valve is pinched you can't
find her exclusively United States you
can if you're in Germany you can if
you're in Spain United States however
nothing
by Sunday once the trend of Hillary
Clinton's character assassination had
subsided the results for the US and
other countries were magically switched
back to being identical now it's worth
noting that her channel is right now as
far as I know it emitted from both sets
of results so everyone out there take
some screenshots do some VPN experiments
I assume they're going to be fixing this
once this video is out and I assume that
someone there is watching this right now
so they may not necessarily be
consistent you don't always have the
same result twice even though that by
the way they're the same heard her
channel is not as prominent as it was
before let me say this
tulsi gabbard is not my candidate like I
said I wouldn't vote for but this this
is chilling especially when you consider
let's think about this for a second
again we stumbled across this
accidentally I don't know if anyone else
has proof that there is someone who
flips a switch on YouTube to make your
channel a part of the preferred channels
network whatever the hell is called we
only found out because of the Fox had
pocalypse and then we only found out
because I suddenly mentioned that this
reeks of election meddling all of a
sudden a phone call and someone says
we've remedied that scenario that means
that if someone can flip that switch and
it's not entirely algorithmic or it's
almost as though the algorithms are
determined by a human being initially
it's not hi robot that means that same
person can flip off the switch for
someone like tulsi gabbard
all this is spine tink it is
hair-raising ly scary and if you're
interested in a fair election whether
for the presidency or just for the
Democratic candidate for the presidency
this should raise some major red flags
the influence that big tech has and
their willingness to manipulate
information in the face of what should
be a democratic election regardless of
whether it's happening to someone I
support or not is terrifying so let me
address some arguments by the way that I
know will be presented and I hope that
you are being skeptical of this I
encourage you to be and I encourage you
to run your own
YouTube and Google will inevitably claim
one of three things or several because
this is what we've run into this is
always what they claim publicly one that
it's simply algorithmic it's not again
this channel is singularly unique in
that we're able to prove that it's not
because our channel was fixed by someone
manually someone flipped a switch
someone could unfair tulsi gabbard to
YouTube may try to pass this off as an
accident a result of a poor Laurel lower
level employee with bad judgment
claiming that this was an oversight and
that the individual didn't make the
proper Corrections they have since
addressed the issue don't buy that
either okay why we've been in direct
contact with decision-makers at YouTube
who are aware of these problems and have
been trying to do damage control to fix
the problems okay it would stand to
reason that the status of a current
presidential candidate who is actively
suing YouTube would be under the same
kind of closed watch from the world's
biggest information and technology
company and that she wouldn't be someone
pod off pawned off on some Patsy for the
higher-ups doesn't pass the sniff test 3
this is another automobile using this is
most important YouTube in the past has
consistently argued that their
algorithms policies that they are the
results
well they argue that it's a result of
value but they do argue let me be clear
here
that the algorithms the policies the
results that you find are often
geographically dependent that's
something that we were told it's
something that many of you have been
told and that's because it's
geographically dependent because it's
designed to best serve viewing audiences
with the most appropriate content for
their search I've heard his argument
made a whole lot and I expect it to be
made now if that's the case I would
implore YouTube please because I know
someone I know someone there's watching
could you please explain to me your
shareholders and in all likelihood a
congressional hearing why you believe it
most appropriate in serving your
audience to block the content of the
United States presidential candidate
exclusively in the country in which she
is running I hope you enjoyed this clip
if you don't these are the ABCs of me
baby you can just click Next video and
put it in double speed of course search
doesn't necessarily work subscriptions
notifications don't necessarily work
just bookmark this page check and we do
a new video every single day except for
Sunday and if you don't want this
content
your join mud club at ladder with
credit.com slash mud club it's only $69
if your student veteran or active
military and if you don't you know
listen I I don't want to say that you're
hell bound but it it doesn't look good
for you